what do you think because you said it
earlier the side that's just like die
hard they're the leftists the Democrats
what do you what do you think they're is
it that that side is just so hardcore
they'll never admit fault because I'm I
don't I don't really have a side day but
like when Trump says stupid stuff like
that I go I go dude he's messing up I'm
in nine different group chats that are
all political and I can't leave because
one of them has a freaking Android they
still to this day bro they won't admit I
will I'll never hear you know what
Biden's messing up or this is they're
just do you think is it they just I
think the machine and the mass
brainwashing is so intense that they
cannot get out of it it's that moment so
when I did Mars podcast a couple weeks I
really want to talk about it and I said
to him you know he kept saying well
Trump's an election denier and I said
well you know Hillary Clinton did call
Trump an illegitimate president she
tweeted it it's on video many times he
was like he's his response to me was no
that never happened and he kind of
screamed it as if I completely made it
up and then once I calmly explained no
it did happen I didn't have Wi-Fi so I
couldn't show it at the moment but I've
we've been tweeting about it he had now
we've ever even texting he now
acknowledges it's real but what it
showed me was wow even Bill Maher right
this is the gold standard for liberalism
in America for 20 years the left now
hates him because he's an actual liberal
right and unfortunately you know the day
before the election he's on MSNBC he's
basically saying you have to vote
Democrat so I I guess I guess my my job
did you did not I did not fully complete
my job but I tried I tried I think I
tried more than probably anyone has
directly to his face on camera uh but
but that moment where he where I'm
telling him what is obvious what is you
know the Stacey Abrams election denial
all of this stuff and that he did not
know I think that's what you're talking
about so then you tell people basic
truths and it is so out of whack with
what they believe because they watch
MSNBC and I mean not that anyone's even
watching it but the culture the culture
stuff that through to people
and that's why they've been censoring us
for so long right that's why this Elon
Musk thing is so massive because I don't
know if you guys noticed this but even
even I think it started this morning on
Twitter if you look at your your
verified you're verified if you look at
your verified mentions now because
people can buy in because of blue bunch
of new ones you don't recognize they're
not verified right so on one hand it's
kind of like all right maybe I don't
want to see all these people but on
another hand what is it doing it's
making it so that all of the political
journalists and Daily Beast journalists
all of these people who got the blue
check because they work at these places
so you somehow think oh they must be
legit and important well now they're
just like everybody else and and that
hopefully will cause some of the change
here where the guys that you're in the
group with will somehow some level of
reality will crash into them because the
censorship at least at the Twitter level
maybe is you know crumbling so with all
the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetainment
it says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
are black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright Tori your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]